responded to a reports of an incident at
the park gain hotel in West George
Street Glasgow at 12:50 p.m. today
officers were on the scene within two
minutes and armed officers shortly
afterwards and the incident was quickly
contained a man was shot by armed police
and have subsequently died six other men
are in hospital for treatment including
a 42 year old police officer who was in
a critical but stable condition the
officers family are aware and being
supported the other men in hospital are
aged 17 18 20 30 8 and 53 liaison
officers have been appointed in all
cases our thoughts are with the families
of those who were injured including our
colleague the officer that was injured
this incident is not being treated as
terrorism and our investigation is
continuing into the circumstances there
is no wider risk to the public
however the street remains closed and
people should avoid the area as would be
the case in any police to charge of
involving a fatality some procurator
physical service has instructed the
police investigations and review
commissioner to investigate thank you
for you time thank you